[Applaudissements]
ok ça va très bien ça va que vous avez
fait vous j'ai payé mes rosiers et parce
qu'on dit taito taita rien ne vaut la
taille de mars
merci ça va les crocus à gilles verdez
et la merci
c'est à lui et j'ai modestement fait mes
débuts sur scène
ah oui c'est la spectacle de julien non
vous les fait monter sur qui il a fait
un petit sketch sur scène
non mais c'est quoi le skate c'était un
petit sketch quoi au juste qu'est ce qui
t'arrive la voilà tu penses tu être là
les halos c'était quoi et surtout ch pas
à mon poste 1 non666 à rester coi aubin
avec un jeu de lumières j'entre et puis
tous un coup de gueule est en fait
j'étais derrière le rideau intelligente
pour ça que c'est enregistré et l'aja
paraît 500 années lumière
vous étiez là oui et hurle sur
l'émission après ce qu'on lui fait c'est
quelle émission au fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je dois reconnaître modestement qu'on a
pris le même vent samedi soir les deux
bien votre spectacle a vraiment vous
avez beaucoup de chance avec ces deux là
par exemple maurice régulier